دور حيوي مهم لاعبه الجيش السوداني منذ
استقلال البلاد في عام
1956 حيث كان الحفاظ على الاستقرار وتهدئه
الاضطرابات الداخليه ومواجهه التحديات
الحدوديه اولويه قصوى مناطق عسكريه ووحدات
قتاليه بريه ونقاط تفتيش عسكريه تابعه
للجيش السوداني موجوده على طول الحدود
التي تربطه بدول الجوارب شمالا هنا حيث
الجار مصر توجد مناطق عسكريه تابعه للجيش
السوداني تحديدا جنوب مثلث حلايب في ولايه
البحر الاحمر كما توجد كاتبه الفرقه
التاسع عشر بمدينه مروي والتي تطل على
طريق شريان الشمال الرابط بين مصر
والسودان على الضفه المقابله مثلث اخر على
الحدود الليبيه السودانيه هناك ايضا قاعده
مركزيه كبيره للجيش السوداني اما
وبحدود بريه تزيد عن 2000 كيلومتر مع
السودان تنتشر فيها قوات مشتركه بهدف
تامين تلك الحدود فقط وفي افريقيا الوسطى
التي تمزقها الحرب يوجد الجيش السوداني
ضمن نقاط تفتيش عسكريه عند الدخول والخروج
اما على الحدود السودانيه
يمكن والتي يمكن ان تتحول لقاعده لتدفق
السلاح ينتشر الجيش السوداني ضمن نقاط
تفتيش كبرى في كسلا والحدود المتاخمه مع
اريتريا ضمن حاميه عسكريه نقطه صراع هنا
وعلى تلك الحدود المشتعله حينا وحين مع
اثيوبيا ينتشر الجيش السوداني في منطقه
الفشقه التي تقع في ولايه الجضارف وايضا
في منطقه الجلابات وولايه النيل الازرق
وفي جنوب البلاد هناك العديد من المناطق
العسكريه ينتشر فيها الجيش السوداني شمال
ابيي شمال ابيي كما نتابع وكذلك في
كوردوفان وولايه النيل الابيض حدود بريه
واسعه يتشاركها السودان مع دول عديده فرضت
على الجيش اتباع استراتيجيه تحكمها ضوابط
عسكريه لحمايه وتعزيز وجوده على طول
الشريط الحدودي لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات